Alam allayikum
Dr. Jak my name Aiz Abdul Aiz Zarnain
I'm a trapeist
u about the explanation about uh the
scripture of Hindus that mention about
many of Ahmed mentioned in the scripture
of Hindu uh I I just uh think that in
the triitaka also Sedarta Gautama also
mentioned as the messenger
uh as a lay person I just want to know
about about him. Is that true that
Sedara Gautama also as the messenger?
Thank you very much.
Brother the question that he wants to
know whether Gautam Buddha Sedara Gautam
>> was he a messenger of God directly?
I don't know of any Quranic verse which
mentions his name. There is one verse in
the Quran
zulk.
There are some people who say zulk may
be kapu from where gautam buddha came.
That's their assumption not direct.
>> So some of the Muslim researchers they
say that the zul mentioned in the Quran
can refer to kapilu talking about
goautam buddha. Maybe I cannot say for
sure. So directly I don't know for sure
any verse in the Quran or any hadith
which talks about Gautam Buddha as
messenger but that doesn't mean he's not
a messenger because as I told you there
is a hadith
in in Mskat al-Masabi
volume number three had number 5373
which says the messenger of Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said there
were 124,000 messengers on the face of
the earth. Now the scholars differ
whether it's a sai or zith but even zadi
has its value not that you know but the
scholars agree there were hundreds and
thousands of messengers by name we only
25 so maybe
gautam buddha was a messenger correct
but even if he was a messenger he was
meant for people of that time
not for now
>> so even if you realize that gautam
buddha was a messenger today you have to
follow whom the last and final messenger
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him do
you understand
>> understand
>> so even if he was alhamdulillah no
problem even if he's not no problem for
knowledge is good but that will not
change your iman
>> of course
>> even the Buddhists today should follow
the Quran even the Christians should
follow the Quran even the Jews should
follow the Quran even the Hindu should
follow the Quran even if Ram was a
messenger of God even if Krishna was a
messenger of God they were messengers of
God of that
For today all the human beings in the
world whether you live in Indonesia or
Malaysia or USA or UK or Saudi Arabia or
India you have to follow the last and
final messenger prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him. Is it clear?
>> Clear. Hope that answers the question.
>> Thank you very much.